we are indeed with him Turkish Genova
after an important Victory against
welcome back to the show how are you
feeling what are your initial feelings
after this game
um I'm feeling all right Tata is she's a
very good friend of mine that's why it's
kind of like sad we had to play
so that's why I feel just sad that I
meet my friend and you guys also did
some training together in preparation
for the Olympiad so you guys know each
other yeah right yeah and then
we probably both expected that this
opening is going to happen so it wasn't
such a big surprise uh for her or for me
we just got a playable position and I
don't know at some point she just made
not the best moves let's go uh through
the game so E46 status does uh play the
French for the most part c692 C6 and
Bishop to D7 Bishop to E2 Knight to E7
Knight 283 explain to us this position
well actually I forgot to check Knight
E7 immediately I was before the game I
for for some reason I checked lines
after ctxd only ctxt and after that
right a different moves yeah nightism
but still I have a I have an idea Knight
day two nights at C2 because uh Knight
on C2 is protecting D4 pawn my Center is
stronger and I can try to like attack on
the king side after and it seems like
this is the type of position that both
of you were willing to accept G3 I think
uh she needs to put the Knight on a F5
not G6 but there is a line with 96 as
well but I didn't remember like I think
Knight F5 is better a night to see two
yeah it's just a line right 96 also a
line but I have a feeling that it's just
worse for uh black after g3h4 perhaps
specifically because what uh you did
with G3 H4 tried to create some problems
for the Knight on June H4 would be
better like uh after I played Knight C2
I I was like I had to just push H4
immediately
yeah that would create more problems for
her that makes sense but you play Knight
C2 and still it does seem like you have
some time to prepare your expansion
right I mean yeah this is the only line
that can happen all right there H5
Knight to h8 and here you play this move
Bishop to F4 which was sure it it feels
like I'm putting some pressure on black
center and the King side but like I
couldn't see how I can like improve the
position so I decided to develop as my
coach mentioned
I remember our talks yeah just decided
to develop I was like okay let's see
speaking of development how about you
finish with a castle I Really Wanna I
didn't want to I guess so I wanted to
play King F1 and King G2 but
Brooklyn H1 is better than on F1 develop
too much yeah it will be too much okay
so you played Bishop D3 maybe Queen B6
would be interesting move for her I
didn't see that and while she was
thinking I realized after Queen B6 I
still have to Castle if I don't do it
her idea is to take on E5 so for example
if you go no yeah if I do that like I'm
still protecting against that I was
going to play Queen E2 anyways but like
if I try to do something on this side
like yeah and no Petri maybe like B3
yeah the idea is that E5 is hanging you
just take on E5 and then suddenly it's
just Checkmate on F2 there's this idea
yes yeah they take and now Checkmate on
F2 yeah okay very interesting idea I
thought maybe she can get something
after Queen B6 but I'm not sure but she
decided to go work to see yeah which is
a good move
and at this point you started spending a
little bit of time and you came up with
this idea of night to age okay I was so
surprised I was like okay it felt like I
had something but like uh and I just
just started to realize I missed
everything that I had and I was like I
can exchange and play a cool position or
I can try something because she didn't
have much time so
I've got 27 minutes at this point for
her and one hour and four minutes for
yourself I didn't see what she can play
here it seems like Knight to E4 would
have been the right move
I don't think you can take if you take
take take after Queen to A5 or queen yes
it seems like uh
yeah usually that will be better than
what she did right yes because my king
is worse here than F1 her pieces are
very centralized and you don't have time
to Castle because of Bishop takes H4 and
actually after Knight to E4 Bishop takes
H4 or Rook takes F4 is a big question
looks better that's why I didn't want to
play Knight H4 I fought with myself
there like I was like Knight H4
shouldn't be right and you were looking
at ideas of Knight G6 yeah and trying to
sacrifice something because if I'm gonna
like exchange the pieces it's so easy
for her to play so I I thought maybe I
really do have something so I just
played Knight H4 but uh I didn't realize
after Knight E4 I was just like
got it got it and after that this was uh
the critical moment right here after she
allowed you to get the Rook on D4 very
nicely uh Place Yasser was very happy to
see that nice blockading look on uh D4
uh begging congratulations and important
victory for you we'll see you in the
rest of your games oh congratulations
indeed big events we see that in the
ladies